Disney's live-action remakes have
dazzled audiences around the world but
it takes a lot of work to make these
movies as visually impressive as they
are don't believe it take a look at how
these Disney live-action remakes look
without the CGI the visual effects
Wizards at MPC spent two long years
building the wild dense world of The
Jungle Book the vast majority of which
was created digitally VFX supervisor
Adam Valdes told animation world Network
when they came to us wanting to do the
movie with blue screen and one kid it
was daunting the company had a team from
its Bangalore office visit 50 different
jungle locations around India to conduct
research for the project they came back
with hundreds of thousands of reference
photos as well as plenty of animal
footage for the visual effects team to
work with but creating the movies
photorealistic animals wasn't even the
hard part making Bagheera and Baloo
interactions with Mowgli feel genuine
was what would ultimately make or break
Jon Favreau's live-action remake of
jungle book and the MPC team knew that
all too well
valdes explains the guys in the rigging
department spent many months developing
and researching facial Anatomy on big
cats wolves and bears as well as how
they move in the end it was an astute
suggestion from the director that made
all the difference
according to Valdes John had this
brilliant idea of using jim henson
company puppeteers to work with Neel
Sethi the actor who plays Mowgli so that
he always had a moving and engaging
puppet a young person leaves that to the
imagination and it came through the
visual effects artist working on the
Jungle Book we're also aware that a lot
was riding on the appearance of the
story's antagonist Shere Khan how old
did you really think you'd survive
against me the human hating tiger was
just a guy in a blue leotard on set but
MPC's team of animators had to turn him
into a fearsome villain
according to the company's VFX
supervisor Adam Valdez the challenge was
in creating animals that were capable of
conveying emotion while still looking
completely natural
he told art of VFX we can all relate to
some things like when a deer reacts with
fright
we understand that but how does a tiger
sit down with intimidating attitude
Valdez and his team were on a constant
hunt for references as they built shear
Khan from scratch he explained many
clips of animal movements were found
recreated and then dialed into the shots
the animators spent a lot of time on the
shots adding
delicate little touches of course
movement is only one aspect of making a
convincing CGI animal but Valdes was
never that concerned about the perb NPC
has so much experience with rendering
animals that the company has it's very
own proprietary tool fertility Valdez
says it's quite powerful and I think we
have the best hair at Birth business to
make it easier for Beauty and the Beast
director Bill Condon to get a grip on a
CGI heavy movie Disney decided to make
the experience as physical as possible
the effects supervisor Kyle McCulloch
told deadline we have the special
effects team build some of the
characters as animatronics so they could
actually be animated and moved around on
set we have life-size builds of them
that we could have on set and then we
have puppets the beast was originally
going to be achieved using practical
effects alone according to McCulloch the
to BFX vendors hired to work on the
remake discussed using a mixture of
makeup and animatronics but in the end
the flexibility of the CGI option was
just too tempting to pass up they also
needed to make sure that the fidelity of
the actors performance wasn't lost by
going digital they would be able to take
the nuance and subtleties of Dan Stevens
performance and reflect them in the
beast himself according to McCulloch if
you were trying to do it under a
thousand pounds of makeup it was never
going to give us the clarity of
performance at digital domain ultimately
achieved and the Beast when Disney
decided to remake 1977's Pete's dragon
it turned to a vendor with a proven
track record of bringing fantasy
creatures to life what at digital whata
has created some of the most memorable
cgi characters in movie history and has
worked with motion capture legend andy
serkis on multiple occasions circus won
praise for his portrayal of evolved
chimpanzee Caesar in the Planet of the
Apes reboot series and what it took
inspiration from that character when it
came to making Pete's titular dragon
Elliot as well as Eric Satan told The
Hollywood Reporter with Caesar you
really feel his pain and happiness and
with Elliot it's the same the big
challenge was getting the emotion out of
Elliot the connection between the dragon
and Pete is such a big part of the pill
unlike Caesar however Elliot wasn't
portrayed by an actor in a motion
capture suit same Dan recalled we had a
green wire mesh head that I would lift
over my head I tried to move the head as
best I thought it would work for the
shot and then we tracked the head with
our CG Elliot Peter Jackson's King Kong
won three Academy Awards in 2006 one of
which was for what at digital's ground
gfx work and the famous age still looks
incredible today but the company became
even better at rendering furry animals
in the decade that followed in an
interview at The Hollywood Reporter why
does Eric sane didn't said King calling
had about 1 million hairs on him and
probably 1/4 of those hairs were
simulated and we interpolated the rest
on Elliot we had 20 million and we
individually simulated each hair so when
Pete is petting or interacting with them
we get the interaction with the hair
according to white as head of creatures
getting Elliot's fur to look real during
close-up interactions was definitely
tricky but the airborne sequences proved
most challenging gos Johnson told
cartoon Bru there are lots of flying
shots in the movie and dialing in the
right amount of wind for a dragon flying
at very fast speeds also took some doing
fans reacted with a mixture of
bemusement at horror when the first
trailer for Disney's live-action Aladdin
drop revealing Will Smith's genie and
all his blueness for the first time in
live certainly the former Fresh Prince
of bel-air star knew he had some
extremely big shoes to fill but so did
the visual effects artist tasked with
turning him into a Disney icon the
remakes VFX supervisor chasse Garrett
told CBR we always sort of knew it was
going to be contentious I suppose that
there would be comparisons between our
genie and the original but ultimately we
felt competent in the character we
created finalizing the genies look
wasn't easy either the team had been
working on the character for a year and
a half by the time the first trailer
came out constantly tinkering with his
appearance according to Jarrett he
wasn't initially supposed to look much
like Smith at all and the VFX team
experimented with a range of more
cartoonish blue genies during
pre-production ultimately however they
decided that they wouldn't be making the
best use of the film's biggest star with
this approach as Jared says when you've
got Will Smith you realize what makes
Will Smith work is all the little Will
Smith mannerisms maybe try putting those
mannerisms on something that isn't Will
Smith it isn't quite satisfying
according to Aladdin's visual effects
supervisor the iconic a whole new world
scene would have played out quite
differently had it not been for director
Guy Ritchie's vision which asked Jarrett
and his team first started working on
the magic carpet ride they envisioned
the journey taking place over the course
of an entire day with the titular street
rat picking up the princess at sunrise
and dropping her back off of the palace
right after sunset Jared told part of
VFX
it worked well but guy felt strongly
that he wanted
all to happen at nights as in the
original so he took helicopter units to
a number of locations to Jordan and
Namibia and Africa unfilmed elements the
footage they captured blended well with
the footage of Meena Massoud and Naomi
Scott's who mind their own recording of
the song in front of a giant blue screen
it literally felt like you know a magic
carpet it was it was incredible
according to Naomi Scott the scene was
quite the workout - since the actors had
to support the wrong weight as the rig
shifted from side to side the dress
transformation scene isn't just one of
the most iconic moments of the original
animated Cinderella it's one of the most
iconic Disney moments period naturally
the studio used snippets from the scene
to promote its live-action remake but
this movie ended up backfiring big time
in one trailer for 2015 Cinderella star
Lily James appears to look a lot thinner
around the waist than she normally does
and the previa FEX footage seemed to
back up claims that her waistline had
been digitally altered the British actor
has denied that this was the case during
an interview with the Los Angeles Times
insisting that she was just a really
healthy person with a naturally small
waist
the actress went on to complain about
people who were in her opinion kicking
up a big bus over nothing she said I
think all that stuff so negative and
you've got to let it wash over your head
but how does she explain images that
seem to prove that her waist
miraculously change sizes and it's all
down to her onset fairy godmother
costume designer Sandy Powell James
explained the skirts big and the corset
pulls me in and that's the point that's
the shape Sandy Powell created Tim
Burton's remake of 1941 s Dumbo was one
of the most ambitious Disney live-action
projects from a visual effects
standpoint largely because of the
eponymous elephant Dumbo was animated
entirely from scratch in certain scenes
but when the blue-eyed elephant needed
to interact with one of the humans in
the story creature actor and Osmond came
in Osman was kitted out with crutch like
arm extensions and had to walk around on
all fours for two to three hours per day
wearing a variety of different green
suits the actor told Insider it's a very
strange job the struggle with the arm
extensions is if you don't get the
rhythm right
if you don't do right arm left leg left
arm right leg you end up walking like a
table husband was also hooked up to an
earpiece so he could communicate with
the film's VFX supervisor NPCs Richard
stammers during this
according to stammers the four foot six
actor was crucial to facilitating
physical interaction and eyelines during
some of the remakes most pivotal moments
stammers told our to BFX having had
their allowed Tim to direct the
performance and we would always do our
first rehearsal and takes with that in
place the hardest part of remaking dumbo
was always going to be the flying scenes
it's easy to suspend your sense of
disbelief for animated movies but when
you're watching a live-action film and
the animals look real that becomes a lot
harder to do in order to make the flight
scenes feel as genuine as possible the
VFX team did a lot of research into
birds and how their wings worked in
relation to their body
NPCs animation supervisor Catherine
Mullen told animation world Network
you're trying to get as much
anticipation and effort into each of the
two or three giant flaps when Dumbo gets
off the ground those were the key
moments also making sure that he isn't
rising up too quickly or easily
Dumbo flying solo was a challenge but
things got even more complicated when
the elephant had riders a six axis rig
was constructed and the VFX team used
what MPC supervisor Richard Sammer's
described as visual production
techniques in a nutshell director Tim
Burton could see a crude version of what
Dumbo would actually look like in the
finished scene there and then stammers
explains Ava Green and the children Niko
Parker and Finley haben got to ride this
rig with each wider mid-shot specially
programmed on set compositing enabled
him to approve performances in context
to the animation within minutes of each
take being captured winnie-the-pooh and
the rest of the Hundred Acre Wood gang
were painstakingly brought to life in
2018 s live-action Christopher Robin but
bringing the honey loving bear and his
friends out of the woods and into
England's capital city was a mammoth
task for the visual effects crew frame
stores VFX supervisor Chris Lawrence
singled out some key members of his team
during an in-depth interview with shoot
online including the vendors global
director of animation Michael Ames
Lawrence explained Ames brought an
incredible attention to detail and the
valuable knowledge of a practitioner
often he would simply sketch exactly
what he wanted I thought with Winnie the
Pooh he achieved one of the most subtle
nuance the animated screen performances
ever seen know this is very confusing it
may be the hunger you're just eating oh
that's right
maybe I didn't eat enough bringing
winnie-the-pooh to the real world meant
that actor Ewan McGregor had to act
opposite some pretty creepy headless
dolls in some seats but this was nothing
new for the Scottish star who told
screen rants I did it all in the Star
Wars movies quite a lot it's like a sort
of skill just something else that you
have to learn to do there are a lot of
weird and wonderful characters in Alice
in Wonderland and bringing each one to
life and live-action posed a unique
challenge for the remakes crew animation
supervisor David shall be told cinema
blend from a technical perspective stain
was incredibly tricky since every shot
required an animated CG body underneath
a photographic elements of Crispin
Glover 's head because the knave of
Hearts is so tall Glover spent the
entirety of the shoot on stilts this
guaranteed that eye lines would match up
and make things a whole lot easier for
the VFX team but for Glover it didn't
come easy
according to Schaub the actors spent
several days hobbling around the set
trying to get the hang of it but at
least the process of getting ready to
shoot wasn't too complicated as Glover
himself says there were no prosthetics
there was nothing like that although
there was a scar application the rest of
it was done in green-screen Tim Burton
didn't return to direct the sequel to
Alice in Wonderland but Disney did
manage to secure the services of Ken
Ralston who helped oversee the visual
effects on the first movie knowing full
well that Alice Through the Looking
Glass was going to be an even bigger
challenge for the visual effects
Department Ralston brought his Sony
Pictures Imageworks colleague J Redd
along for some much-needed support red
told animation world Network when we
started looking at the show we knew it
was going to be gigantic there was more
variety in this one than the first one
you could safely say it was bigger there
were more varied environments than in
the first film star Mia Wasikowska
worked with a lot of green screen in the
first movie so she was well used to it
by the time the sequel began shooting
the major difference the second time
around was that her role was a lot more
physical with more running and jumping
involved the actor told worki inspired
sustaining that level of energy when you
have quite little coming back at you in
terms of the sets is challenging it's
just a big green blob of light and
there's not much we had a few more sets
on this film which was really great but
otherwise it's quite like an abstract
experience when Angelina Jolie accepted
the lead role in Disney's Maleficent she
brought in her own personal makeup
artist and a special-effects makeup guru
together they created
Antti heroines look staying as close to
the animated version from 1959 Sleeping
Beauty as possible the corrupted facial
prosthetics to give jolie those high
cheekbones which reportedly made execs
at the mouse house rather nervous are in
tighten the makeup artist who created
said facial prosthetics told fashionista
they were like wait what prosthetics on
Angelina why are we covering her up they
were not very keen on it Jolie insisted
on keeping them and ultimately got her
way but the movie still utilized plenty
of visual effects after all this is a
fantasy movie featuring some major
action sequences the kind of scenes that
can only be achieved with CGI according
to Kelly port the movie's VFX supervisor
he and his team decided to adopt a less
is more approach which paid off
handsomely
he says for me visual effects are a tool
and should always be thought of as a
tool to support the film they always
need to serve the purpose of the film
and move the story along that's when
they're most successful with Maleficent
we knew what was working well and what
to pay attention to
according to NPCs Jessica Norman Disney
wanted the latest in visual effects for
2019 s Maleficent mistress of evil there
were over a thousand VFX artists working
on the big-budget sequel at one stage
many of them pouring their time and
energy into Angelina Jolie's flying
sequences Norman told our two VFX the
actress and the other fake characters
were filmed whilst attached to operated
tuning fork rigs on a blue-screen stage
in some shots we attached CG wings some
shots are full or partial CG takeovers
in a behind-the-scenes featurette jolie
revealed what it's like being strapped
into a rotating tuning fork break for
hours on end they're doing the up in the
day
but your body is dictating whether you
turn left or right and then they have to
go with you Joe Lee later told Hello
magazine that she and co-star Sam Riley
even had a near miss while filming a
flying sequence thankfully though they
both made it out in one piece
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]